Bonjour, je suis La Prof de la chaîne youtube
Chroniques de Prof, qui parle d'Histoire principalement.
Je vais vous parler du Roman National, c'est
à dire la manière dont on a pu écrire l'Histoire
à travers le temps.
Et donc le Roman National définit la manière
dont on écrivait l'Histoire au XIXe siècle
mais on va un peu développer sur les autres
périodes.
Quand j'étais en licence, j'avais une amie
de lycée qui m'avait dit "à force, tu dois
tout savoir sur l'Histoire", parce que pour
elle comme j'étudiais l'Histoire je devais
tout connaître, et je pense qu'elle disait
ça parce qu'elle envisageait l'Histoire comme
une succession de dates et de personnages.
Un peu comme ça.
Et forcément si on s'en tient à cette vision,
on peut assez rapidement se dire c'est bon,
je sais tout de l'Histoire, je peux tout gagner
au Trivial Poursuite".
Cette manière d'enseigner l'Histoire, c'est
plutôt celle qu'on avait au XIXe siècle.
On l'a un peu connue quand on était en école
primaire pour certains, quand on étudiait
Vercingétorix, le vase de Soissons...
Et elle nous vient d'une époque où on met
en place l'école gratuite, laïque et obligatoire,
on réfléchit à une manière de mettre en
valeur l'héritage français à travers des
personnages importants et des événements
emblématiques qui montrent la grandeur du
pays.
Ernest Lavisse écrit un manuel scolaire à
cette époque, et pour lui l'Histoire s'apprend
par le cœur: les personnages qu'on étudie
son des héros nationaux.
Je vous ai mis une petite citation de son
livre, il faut aimer la France et on illustre
ça par des héros nationaux.
Plusieurs raisons expliquent la mise en place
de ce type d'Histoire: la première est une
raison religieuse.
A l'époque la plupart des écoles sont tenues
par des congrégations religieuses, et ça
ne plaît pas trop à la IIIe République
qui a été mise en place depuis assez peu
de temps.
On décide de faire fermer ces écoles pour
pouvoir ouvrir des écoles républicaines
dans lesquelles on enseignera ce qu'on veut.
La deuxième raison, c'est aussi qu'on veut
former de bons citoyens.
En 1848 a été mis en place le suffrage universel
masculin, et donc les français ont pu voter,
et ils ont voté pour Napoléon III qui a
mis fin à la République et qui a mis en
place le Second Empire.
Les français ont voté pour quelqu'un qui
a mis fin à la république qui leur avait
permis de voter.
C'est un petit peu ballot.
C'est pourquoi on veut éviter ça en permettant
aux français d'avoir une meilleure culture
républicaine.
La troisième raison enfin, c'est que pendant
la guerre de 1870 les français ont perdu
contre les prussiens, et on considère (ce
qui n'est pas forcément vrai, mais à l'époque
c'est ce qu'on pense) que les français ont
été battus parce qu'ils étaient moins patriotes
que les prussiens et parce qu'ils s'y connaissaient
moins bien en Histoire et en Géographie.
C'est pour ça qu'on veut mettre en place
une école qui mette en avant l'unité nationale
du pays, pour ça on utilise l'exemple des
gaulois, mais aussi l'unité religieuse.
Pour ça on va parler du baptême de Clovis
et aussi de l'exemple de Jeanne d'Arc.
La vision de l'Histoire qu'avaient les élèves
au XIXe siècle était donc biaisée, incomplète
et parfois complètement inventée.
Par exemple, les Gaulois qu'on imaginait bagarreurs,
sauvages et vivant dans la forêt, c'était
une vision un peu décalée par rapport à
la réalité.
Cette manière d'enseigner l'Histoire dans
les écoles correspond à l'école historique
méthodique.
L'école méthodique est un courant historiographique,
l'historiographie c'est l'Histoire de l'Histoire,
ou l'Histoire de comment on écrit l'Histoire,
et donc c'est un courant historiographique
du XIXe siècle (je vous ai mis l'exemple
de deux personnages emblématiques).
Pour l'école méthodique comme pour les programmes
de l'époque, on s'intéresse au biographique,
au politique, à l'événementiel et surtout
aux sources écrites, on s'intéresse assez
peu aux autres sources alors que maintenant
on est un peu plus diversifiés.
Dès 1903, cette école est critiquée par
François Simiand dans Les Trois idoles de
la tribu des historiens, qui considère que
l'école méthodique est politique, individuelle
et chronologique, donc à nouveau biographique,
événementielle etc, pour lui ce n'est pas
très bien parce qu'il faudrait essayer un
peu plus de contextualiser, d'élargir son
propos.
Pour ça, je vais partir sur deux exemples:
Par exemple, dans le Dimanche de Bouvines
de Georges Duby, qui est paru en 1973, on
l'histoire d'une bataille donc c'est bien
de l'histoire événementielle; mais dans
son livre, il s'efforce de montrer le contexte:
pourquoi a eu lieu cette bataille, comment
ça s'est passé, quelle était la société
de l'époque qui a mené à cette bataille.
Un deuxième exemple passe par la microhistoire,
qui est un autre courant historiographique
plutôt des années 1960-70.
Dans la microhistoire, on s'intéresse à
un individu complètement anonyme, ou à un
cas banal, une affaire judiciaire oubliée...
Et à partir de là on s'efforce de montrer
la société de l'époque.
Là, Alain Corbin a pris une commune au hasard
dans les archives, dans cette commune il a
pris un personnage au hasard, et il en a fait
la biographie.
On s'est retrouvés avec la biographie de
Louis-François Pinagot, qui était sabotier
à Origny-le-Butin au XIXe siècle.
A partir de là, il montre le monde rural
de la France au XIXe siècle.
Ça c'est de la microhistoire, et c'est un
autre courant historique.
J'ai fait un bon en avant, mais c'est pour
dire que l'Histoire du style "nos ancêtres
les Gaulois" ne fait pas long feu dans la
recherche historique au XXe siècle.
Par contre, dans les programmes, elle reste
un peu plus longtemps.
Maintenant, on va s'intéresser aux différents
programmes qui se sont succédé et qui suivent
plus ou moins les recherches historiques.
Des années 1880 à 1955, on reste dans le
Roman National, dans une Histoire plutôt
traditionnelle de la France.
Mais à partir de la Deuxième Guerre Mondiale,
on sort d'un conflit qui a bouleversé toute
l'Europe et les autres continents, et on commence
donc à s'intéresser aux civilisations étrangères.
Ça serait bien de s'intéresser à ses voisins
pour ne pas reproduire ça, donc on introduit
dans les programmes des études sur des sociétés
extra-européennes.
Ensuite à partir des années 70, on a une
nouvelle approche de l'Histoire qui est plus
thématique: par exemple on étudie la naissance
et le développement des villes, ou encore
l'évolution des navires et des transports
maritimes.
On ne fait plus une histoire qui irait d'un
point A à un point B, on s'intéresse à
des thèmes qu'on développe un peu plus.
Ensuite dans les années 80, par contre, on
a un retour en arrière.
On était partis sur une Histoire fort thématique,
ça perturbe certaines personnes qui se disent
"mais on fait plus l'Histoire traditionnelle,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?". Il y a une Une
du Figaro qui date des années 70-80 où il
était écrit "Français, on n'enseigne plus
l'Histoire à vos enfants".
Ça fait peur, on écrit de nouveaux programmes.
Et dans ces nouveaux programmes on met à
nouveau en avant une culture commune, une
culture républicaine, nationale et aussi
européenne.
C'est également là qu'on remet en place
l'éducation civique.
Dans cette culture commune on retrouve un
peu le Roman National, d'autant plus qu'à
cette époque on a de plus en plus d'enfants
issus de l'immigration dans les classes et
on veut qu'ils adhèrent aussi à cette culture
commune.
Enfin, en 1995, on a un nouveau revirement
avec les notions qui apparaissent de mémoire,
de patrimoine et de devoir de mémoire.
Notamment en lien avec la Seconde Guerre Mondiale,
la mémoire de la Shoah, et la guerre d'Algérie.
On multiplie les commémorations, les créations
de musées, les monuments...
Et tout ça se ressent dans les programmes.
Par exemple, Nicolas Sarkozy avait voulu mettre
en place la lecture de la lettre de Guy Mocquet
dans tous les lycées.
Ça c'est typiquement un exemple de l'usage
de la mémoire dans les cours d'Histoire.
Les programmes actuels mélangent un peu tout
ça: en primaire on a un retour de repères
classiques, on étudie Alésia, on aborde
le baptême de Clovis...
Par contre au collège on a une ouverture
vers d'autres civilisations: par exemple en
6e on étudie l'Inde et la Chine anciennes,
en 5e on étudie les royaumes africains médiévaux...
Et au lycée on peut avoir certaines études
plus thématiques à nouveau, sur un temps
long, par exemple sur les médias et l'opinion
publique depuis l'affaire Dreyfus, donc tout
le long du XXe siècle.
Alors on a comme ça des approches très différentes,
qui peuvent du coup rendre un peu confuse
la manière d'enseigner l'Histoire aux élèves
puisqu'ils étudient des "types" d'Histoire
différents en fonction de la primaire, du
collège et du lycée.
Je me suis pas seulement attardée sur le
Roman National dans cette présentation.
Ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que l'écriture
de l'Histoire évolue tout le temps, pas seulement
en fonction des événements mais aussi en
fonction de l'intérêt des historiens pour
tel ou tel "type" d'Histoire, et également
des enjeux politiques derrière l'écriture
de l'Histoire et des programmes scolaires.
Si vous voulez me retrouver, j'ai pas mis
de petit logo comme la personne d'avant mais
j'ai une chaîne qui s'appelle Chroniques
de Prof dans laquelle je fais des tas de vidéos
historiques et je vais laisser la parole à
la personne suivante.
Merci !